edward snowden says we are all going to
eat crickets
people are like i'm not going to eat the
crickets oh you're going to eat the
crickets brother they're going to be
everywhere they're going to put them in
hot pockets your kids are going to be
like mom mom i want the pizza crickets
he's not wrong i saw this conspiracy
theory if you can call it that i don't
know they said
in order to get people to eat crickets
you got to make them hungry first
because if people are hungry they will
eat anything
so now we're looking at these food
shortages we're looking at what's going
on the dutch farmers
dutch farmers being told not to farm
at the same time the tiniest of food
shortage is coming how the does that
make sense
it doesn't so we are going to all starve
maybe not us here and many at home might
not if they bought their emergency food
oh that's right but y'all are going to
be eating crickets you know why he's
right about the hot pockets there's
already a company in canada have you
seen this the president's choice why
they put crickets in it they sell bags
of crickets no no i'm talking about
there's a there's a a chip company that
puts cricket into their snacks
so that you're like protein inching your
way there and an extra crunch
so imagine you get like they're like
cheeto puffs
and you eat a cheeto puff and it's made
of corn and cheese and stuff like this
is good so they mix in maybe like five
percent cricket added protein
and then you're like this is good you do
that for a year or two and you keep
increasing the level of cricket in the
food and then eventually you do that
with cattle and like barley and molasses
you just increase the ration until
they're able to eat it
they're going to call it something else
they're not going to call it cricket
they're going to call it like that's
coke like escargot yeah no it's going to
help it's going to be called like um
arachne protein or something you know
like
and you're eating spiders or whatever
it's chitin so there's going to
lobsters so why would you not these are
just the crickets i don't think look
people ate high fructose corn syrup and
never knew what it was no one came to
them one day and said we're putting this
in your food they just started eating
and they're like oh so chitin there you
go you're gonna you're gonna be ordering
a burger and they're gonna be it's gonna
be like 87 percent pure beef with extra
chitin and you're gonna go i don't know
and you're eating cricket well we eat
carrageenan which is an ice cream that's
actually from seaweed and it gives ice
cream like its shape it helps keep its
shape after it melts a little bit which
is really interesting if you don't know
that about the fact that seaweed is an
ice cream kind of gross not really i
don't know there you go gorillas they're
going to call it grilles there you go
yeah depending on what they use cricket
juvenile gorillas campestris
and it's going to be like the
ingredients of your your chips it's
going to be like whole corn yeah cheese
enzymes grill this protein and you're
going to be like oh okay and you're not
going to think twice about eating the
crickets big banner on the side now with
five percent more gorillas that's right
oh boy i mean gorilla sounds pretty good
right gorilla grilled food yeah yeah if
you like have you tried grilled grillas
you're going to be like what's grill
it's like a grill thing it's like a
thing they do in the grills man like
what i ordered cheeseburgers and it was
90 beef 10 grillis what's that oh it's
like it's for grilling yeah uh-huh and
they'll do commercials where they're
like grilled burger
i got a commercial for kelp burger
not good gross yeah not good yeah uh i
like you know like mushroom and black
beans mixes with like you know
vegetables and stuff that's pretty good
seaweed but they try and do all sorts of
stuff but ladies and gentlemen y'all
going to be in the crickets whether you
want to or not you will not be able to
hide
yeah and i told you president's choice
is selling a pc cricket protein bar
grillions they call it brilliance we
were right i was right oh my god no way
that's amazing i just dm
that's awesome
how do you spell it g-r-i-l-l-o-n-s
they slightly altered it that's great
that's insane
and this is on their website i would i
thought this maybe it was
yeah grill on cricket grill it's
grillons yeah g-r-i-c cricket protein
bar
yeah chocolate mmm yummy who wants to
try cc cricket
from nutritionix
cricket grillin's powder i was close
because the cricket was grillous camp
certris or
it's really astringent is the way they
describe the flavor
it's like it's sour and bitter bitter
yeah yep it's sour if you season it i
think it'll be fine but i put some salt
yeah but you had some vinegar diluted it
you did like half cricket half flour
it was it was too much cricket powder
too much cricket yeah if i had done more
wheat flour with powder
okay great so
i think i'm okay with cricket i'm not
i'm not too worried you know people eat
like you said lobsters like they eat you
know birds they eat
what's happening what's next
first guy to ever eat uh an oyster you
knew was crazy someone looked at that
thing and opened it and they were like
eat it like i'm not eating but i love it
i don't know
early humans ate random stuff anyway
yeah they were like well i'm dying i'll
eat this rock
it's better than nothing eat this bark
you know i like the joke it's like um
every time you eat mushrooms you need to
give thanks to every human who tried
mushrooms so you knew which one was safe
to eat yeah yeah because they died yeah
they're like i'll try it for that
but i mean up until
you know the the the industrial
revolution dutch farmers and and power
the future
the majority of the world was hungry all
the time i mean hunger drove a drove war
it drove economies i mean kings were
hungry everyone was hungry yes yes
people lived in hunger a lot of the wars
were fought over just making food taste
better yeah true pepper absolutely they
were like that ship's carrying
peppercorn fire
yeah seized the peppercorn and they'd
bring it to the king and he'd be like oh
and now we just have it on like every
diner table oh exactly and but for you
know the the miracles of of the fossil
fuel industry and modern technology and
and we can argue at the 30 000 foot
level should we use fossil fuels in the
cultivation of our agriculture
i'll have that conversation should we as
a but we do
and yet these people as i'm not have
explained to you you know better than i
do but the world economic forum and the
the klaus schwabs and the the john
kerry's are like we shouldn't and
holland's going to lead the way or sri
lanka is going to lead the way in all
these countries and now as all of a
sudden it's like wait a second but but
we do use although sri lanka more than
than the netherlands netherlands is more
of a land seizure right but but sri
lanka well we're not going to use these
anymore well now we're in famine and and
we the john kerry is the klaus schwabs
from 7 000 15 000 miles away look at it
and say boy this is terrible what's
happening over there but if you're a sri
lankan and you're in true famine yeah
how did your experiment go because
schwab is not going to stop eating
steaks no he's not going to be the one
putting crickets on his hamburgers well
he is
how old is that guy anyway ancient yeah
he's probably like i only have like
three years left anyway so i will eat
filet mignon until then
i can't believe i was told someone said
they liked porterhouse better than
tenderloin i'm like that doesn't make
sense to you but it's true people do i
like i look at a menu and i'm like well
i have any other option because some
people just like t-bones or i like new
york strip
strip steak i mean it's good but maybe
it's a cost thing maybe i want to spend
the money on tenderloin
i don't know that's kind of why don't
they why don't they just feed the cow
crickets there you go
just say it call it pig cow i'm eating
pig tonight yeah
tonight
crickets man i have no personal issue
with eating bugs i have an issue with
people being forced to eat bugs or
tricked into eating bugs
or anything while they still eat steak
yes it's going to be like v for vendetta
yes when she's like is this real butter
oh i've never had this that was a child
how did you get it he's like i stole it
from chancellor sutler's personal supply
card or whatever but it's not it's also
not just like them being tricked into
eating crickets it's them being forced
crickets because that is the only food
that's been made available to them they
they lose out on the choice and over
time i think you're you're right about
them putting in pizza pockets it's like
beef is not going to be affordable to a
middle-class family much
less anyone below um and and then the
response is well we have these cheap
crickets here you can feed your kids you
can feed a family of six with these
so
you know whether is it them knowing it
or not
just the fact why crickets though
aren't there better tasting bugs i'm
sure roly-polies taste better than
crickets are you going to kill bugs for
those who don't live in chicago or i
don't know you guys call them rolly
polly's right i have no idea what the
potato bugs i think i call them no no no
potato bugs are different
pill bug maybe crickets don't have
anything in them that is inherently
dangerous certain bugs slugs are deadly
don't need to ever eat a slug oh yeah i
heard a story about the guy who ate it
off the ground as a dare and then
yeah so there are certain bugs you can't
eat but maybe crickets are totally clean
this car goes pretty good i don't know
one of the one of the projects for
timcast.com as you guys expand is you
need to have
like a fun
press accountability
uh component where you go up to
reporters who wrote glowing stories
about the future who were proven
categorically wrong and ask where they
are like the people who wrote about sri
lanka 2025 will be the the cleanest
country or the the richest country in
the world per capita or you know the
paul krugman's who are like the internet
is going to be gone by the year 2000 or
just i mean the the press when it comes
to climate issues food issues socialism
issues they always write these glowing
reports about how great things are going
to be in three years everything falls to
pot and then they're like ho home new
story yeah well i think it was tucker
that was bringing up that like um
uh myanmar i believe it is sri lanka i'm
sorry
they're the ones who had the best esg
scores in the world followed by like
south africa i'm like these places are
not doing well so i don't know what a
high esg score looks like but it is not
good for the people
to find the story from the guy i know i
texted it to myself because it was so
great but this was the guy who wrote the
story about how uh
sri lanka is going to be the greatest
country in the world in a couple of
years and oh here it is jason hickle hey
jason's hope you're listening jason's
got 200 000 plus followers on social
media he's a professor uh he's got lots
of things in his professor
blah blah blah but he wrote the story
about yeah sri lanka was going to be the
greatest stagger a whole thread about
how great sri lanka is going to be when
they adopted all the csg stuff and you
want to go find jason hickle and say
jason where are you now because you know
what there's a sri lankan dad who's
feeding his kid crickets because they're
friggin starving to death they're
probably licking are you are you it's
not even are you good
how are things for the jason hickle
household
no compunction no sense of boy real we
really like like like took a turd in the
bed with this one they just move on you
know what though man it's all the big
cities and uh
after these past several years of
telling people to get away from cities
at a certain point it's just like i
don't know what else to do for you yeah
look
you can't grow food you can't grow
enough food to feed your family in the
city
you move out of the cities move to the
middle of nowhere you learn how to take
care of yourself and you can start
creating your own food so for instance
like for breakfast i eat eggs straight
from my own chicken's butt
granted we give the chickens feed but we
also there's also the bug technique
where you put the wood on the ground and
then every morning you lift the water up
and move it and the chickens run over
and eat all the bugs you let the
chickens graze in the grass and eat the
bugs all day and the berries and then
they poop out the eggs for you then in
the winter you slowly run out of
chickens as you eat the chickens but we
got a ton we got like 30 or something
out there now it's crazy and then we
have uh we started cocktown i don't know
if we told you we got too many roosters
well it means rooster yeah what you guys
are laughing at yeah that's
not a laughing no no no no it's not not
a laugh we got too many roosters
and uh the roosters can't live together
with girls yeah so we move just don't
call it cocktown.com because well you
can that's a good one
it may be taken all right it may already
be taken
right now everyone
no don't do anything
i'm not going to cocktown.com oh my gosh
it exists okay strictly for adults yeah
that's not show new york yeah okay yeah
we have all the berries out here
we had wild black raspberry and it's
such a weak plant it got strangled out
by the surrounding plants and was like
it's a bummer
the wine raspberries take over
everything and they're everywhere and
they're delicious but uh
it's crazy living moving out of the city
and now it's like
maybe five percent or even actually not
even i think maybe around like 20 or 30
of the food i eat probably comes from
my like my own source like it's the
chickens i eat i eat their eggs for the
most part it's like breakfast it's their
eggs
and then i have dinner so it's
i say like 20 because
it's just the eggs and then i'll have
dinner later and the dinner is more
substantial for the most part that's a
decent amount when we were gardening it
was much less but i would do like eggs
and like peppers and stuff
when
look when it hits the fan we got look at
this story it's from cbc from 2019
cricket beer ladies and gentlemen right
when it hits the fan
you are going to be eating crickets
and we're going to have fresh eggs
because we moved out and we got more
space we got away from those cities but
the cost of living in a city is nuts
it's five thousand dollars per month on
average for an apartment in new york
city for that cost you can buy yourself
a mansion
five grand or a hundred acre farm or 100
acre farm
and then that's where i am and then you
can just slowly start figuring out how
like use the luxury of the modern era to
figure out how to survive on your own
before it's too late man
yeah you know because we got
amazing tools and electricity and so
we're the chickens we don't need to have
chickens we like having chickens the
chickens are funny we film the chickens
people watch chickens and then we eat
the chicken's butt bounty those eggs
every day yeah we got so many that's
crazy
but bounty that's what it's called the
bounty of the chickens but thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast irl
come hang out live monday through friday
at 8 p.m eastern time super chat we'll
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you